you remember the movie on television a
while back with muhammad ali called
freedom road
about a freed slave during
reconstruction
well we saw it here in austin but the
folks in boston didn't get to see it
station wbz tv said well due to the
current racial tension that exists in
the boston area and because it wishes to
avoid contributing either directly or
indirectly to these tensions wbz tv will
not air the nbc movie
now one
black person said well
they don't cancel any white shows
because it's going to stir up the white
kids
well
we i guess we stir up most everybody
here in alternative views news magazine
at least we try
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
good evening welcome to alternative
views as you might guess the tv
presentation of the events in iran has
been atrocious there's been a complete
failure to explain the events and to
raise the real questions confronting the
american government and the american
people there have also been some
extremely irresponsible examples of
reporting by barbara walters of abc and
tom snyder and nbc which we'll discuss
tonight in order to present a more
rational discussion of the political
moral and legal issues concerning the
events in iran tonight on alternative
views we will have visiting with us john
stockwell the former c.i.a case officer
who will help explain some of the role
of the cia
in the iranian situation we will have
john duncan of the texas civil liberties
union that will talk about the possible
violation of the civil rights of iranian
students and we will have christie
birdfeather a representative of a
coalition against racism and
intervention in the middle east that
will talk about a local group that is
trying to prevent a military
intervention in that area
let's have some news
as usual we start off with a report on
oil there's the liberty lobby magazine
spotlight reports that a congressman
says
that exxon actually rigged the oil
crisis or one of the participants in
rigging the oil crisis which we've just
gone through we've been telling you that
for a long time
they he points to a
gao report along this line and also the
cia report which is a rather curious
thing where our own cia is doing
undercover intelligence works against
the so-called american multinational
corporation isn't it
i guess that tells them for what it is
but now the middleton newspaper
also has an analysis of what is
happening in relation to oil
and they say as in the past opec is
falling following behind the price
increases of the major oil companies and
it works this way it looks like the same
thing was happening several months back
that the
spot price for oil in other words the
independent market
is roughly forty dollars a barrel which
is considerably more than what the oil
companies pay opec under long-term
contracts so what the oil companies do
they buy the
oil from opec go and sell it on the
spark spot market make huge profits out
of it then the arabs they say hey we
want part of that gravy too so we're
going to raise our prices so that we can
get more and then back and forth it goes
and the whole price just gets out of
hand it's very much controlled it's not
out of hand but we get it in the neck
but actually oil consumption in the u.s
is down right now
the industry's deliveries of gasoline
dropped five percent in september and
for heating fuels a drop of 7.2
percent
uh does this
go along with what you've been
reading also along the lines of what's
happening in the oil world well it's
obvious that oil prices are not a
function of demand
in the face of declining demand oil
prices continue to skyrocket and this
really zeros in on the 18 major oil
firms that are in absolute total control
of the world oil situation
it's completely out of the hands of the
government right
well and now there's more hoarding of
oil going on that they're getting ready
for another round of big shortages and
boosts
the key reason for the high spot price
right now is that the oil companies are
hoarding millions upon millions of
barrels of oil business week reports of
stockpiling
is
going on that the tanks are
being filled worldwide and also the
economist says that they're telling the
tankers to slow down steam slowly across
the ocean because we
want to make sure that as little oil as
possible actually gets to the market
because if too much comes and there'll
be perhaps a drop in price and maybe
even a shattering of the
of opec well a few weeks ago frank the
wall street journal actually came out
and said that indeed a handful of oil
companies are jacking up the world price
of oil but they failed to name the
companies involved
well the recent energy department report
said that oil refiners increased the
retail price of home heating oil twice
as fast as the price of crude oil
between january 77 and 79 and there was
an unpublicized civil trial in nova
scotia canada back four years ago but
nothing was reported until 1979
uh in september 30th in the new york
times but it showed a very vivid picture
of the fraud and profiteering by exxon
which of course is the world's largest
oil company it showed that the company
disguised increases in its profit
margins by backdating them to blend in
with the price increases tied to the
opec price increases
they use transactions among their
subsidiaries to justify the price
increases to their customers and they
also used offshore corporations to
launder and artificially inflate the
price increases these corporations were
organized to avoid millions of dollars
in taxes well the big banks do that also
for sure
to underline the importance of this
frank most of us i think are well aware
now that the oil companies third quarter
profits this year were absolutely
astronomical some firms reporting
profits up as much as two thousand
percent
and of course the uh the retort to this
uh by a company spokesman was that these
these profits were made strictly from
overseas operations well let's let's
outline how profits are made on overseas
operation exxon
or buys from one of its subsidiaries in
saudi arabia at 18 it turns around and
sells it to a subsidiary in the bahamas
at 25
and we're looking at seven dollars
profits made from overseas operation now
the subsidiary in the bahamas does
nothing more to the oil then turn around
and sell it to an exxon refinery in the
united states for 35 dollars there's
another 10 that is called profits made
from overseas operations frank
well what else you got any goodies there
well along the of course we seem to be
doing most of our news on all companies
lately but you know that's where the
action is uh you know it's like they
asked willie sutton why he kept robbing
banks and he said that's where the money
is
um this is under the category of hedge
you win tails i lose frank phillips
petroleum and the government reached a
200 million dollar accord
phillips along with city service along
with gulf oil current mcgee and most of
the major oil companies have been have
been guilty
which is no surprise to most of us of
overcharging us
billions of dollars on on what they what
they're making
and so phillips has agreed that even
though they didn't do this
that they would not only not do it again
in the future
but they have agreed to
quote pay back unquote the money now
this is how they plan to pay the 200
million dollars back
it'll come in the form of 100 million
dollars in added spending on oil
production 22 million to add to the
supplies of heating oil and 75 million
in price boost that they will forego
so when when we find somebody guilty of
overt um i won't say criminal but overt
unconscionable activities
they don't really have to pay the money
back they simply agree not to charge us
in the future
this is the second time in two years
that they've done that yeah there was a
story exactly like that uh about nine
months ago yeah
uh a related thing you remember several
uh several months ago al we talked about
the a solar
the hydrogen development company
that developed
a car
which they said they could mass produce
it's an inexpensive photovoltaic cell
that would convert sunlight into
electricity the electricity is then used
in an electrolytic process to convert
water into liquid hydrogen which the
company officials say is non-explosive
and is similar to propane as fuel which
means it can be burned naturally and
internally
and totally non-polluting too yeah but
now the bad museum that was a great
thing a big breakthrough right
well u.s district court in los angeles
is seeking the company sued in the court
seeking eight million dollars in damages
against the u.s department of energy in
the
general services administration the
company contends that former secretary
of energy james schlesinger
arbitrarily blocked the company proposal
for a five million dollar order to
convert government-owned automobiles to
run on hydrogen
and one company officials said we've
successfully run a hydrogen car all the
way across the united states
and if we're allowed to enter the market
we will wipe out
a multi-trillion dollar industry
the oil industry of course
will not just be competing with them
we'll wipe them out
the company claims that the u.s energy
cartels are responsible for the
company's failure to get this federal
endorsement which is no surprise but it
also points up to the many many times
we've pointed out on this program that
there are many workable alternatives not
only to the internal combustion engine
but improvements on it and also many
workable alternative sources of energy
which can be tapped right now if it were
possible to do so
well speaking of being tapped
well now i guess that'd be too cynical
there
we've had before stories about
right-wing cubans down in miami who were
just terrorized people particularly
other cubans who are wanting to show
what life is like down in cuba right now
and maybe show films or get together to
discuss in the situation in cuba and try
to get people to go back just to visit
well you remember the cuban film
memories of underdevelopment it's been
here in austin a couple of times there
was a
meeting in which people were viewing the
film it was broken up by our members of
an anti-castro group called abdallah
they smashed the film projector beat up
brigade activists and stole several
hundred dollars and fled after firing
shots in the air
then the film was rescheduled to show in
temple israel in miami but after several
threats by these right-wing
thugs the temple administrators canceled
the showing this is a continuation of
things that have been happening down
there
what's next this is related to a show
that we're going to be showing
i guess this this show on iran
as a high school civics class in maine
took the bill of rights took the name
off it made a petition out of it and of
course is characteristic of the american
public
65 percent of the people signed a
petition banning the bill of rights
because they were afraid it might coddle
criminals
we've seen similar studies done in
detroit
where 60 percent of the people in
detroit didn't even know what it was
and about 75 percent or 80 percent of
the republic thought it was communist
plot
and so we talked about violation of
rights in this country it's it's kind of
interesting to put it into perspective
that the majority of american public
simply don't they don't know what their
rights are and when you show them what
the bill of rights looks like they think
it's either communistic or
or
something that is you know in favor of
criminals as opposed to the average
american citizen
also in the news this is something i
usually do before thanksgiving
since most of you by the time you see
this will have already consumed mass
quantities of your thanksgiving dinner
i would like to reiterate
where where your meal is more than
likely to come from here in the state of
texas
if you had shrimp in texas it may have
come from coca-cola deviled eggs may
have come from cargill tomatoes may have
come from the ogden corporation your
beef probably came from gulf and western
sugar from h.l hunt creamed by etna life
and casualty citrus fruits from
international minerals and chemicals
almonds and walnuts from getty oil
company your macadamia nuts from iu
international duckling probably came
from schlitz your turkey came from
eastmark your applesauce came from
american brands which is not too bad
because at least they are a food
conglomerate potatoes came from u.s
steel carrots from teneco chicken from
greyhound ham from ltv corn by boeing
if you had if you had wine it might have
come from prudential if you had
mushrooms it might have come from clorox
and that's frightening because we
usually think of clorox in terms of
bathroom bowl cleaners oh that's better
than wine coming in
white wine and if you had salmon it
might have come from unilever so
as you're thinking back on your
thanksgiving dinner keep keeping keep in
mind the corporations that are
responsible for it
well let's see what is happening in the
rest of the world
to begin we'll talk to john stockwell
and we'll ask john
why are the iranians hate the shot so
much and why are they so angry with the
american government what is the facts
behind this
you know i see the situation in iran as
being symptomatic
of a world scale problem that that i and
others have been signaling in books and
lectures and articles for
several years now
of
an extremely callous and abusive policy
by our government particularly the
secret government the cia
towards people in the third world and by
this i mean this endless string of
covert actions that have been designed
that have killed a lot of people and
been designed in many cases to install
shaws and samosas and support the
batistas and and put the pinochets in
power
and these dictators that we've uh
affiliated ourselves with supported put
in power
propped them up train their secret
police
have in many cases proceeded to kill
a lot of the local citizens
and in country after country there is
great bitterness mounting
towards the united states for the cia's
actions in many cases of course most
american citizens are pretty innocent
but
but our ci is not innocent and this is
the case in point the cia in 1953 pulled
off a coup kermit roosevelt
the ci has been very proud of this
action and roosevelt used to lecture all
of the training classes including mine
in 1965
telling how he ousted mosudek and
installed the shah in power and then
they would also mention training
formation and training of the savak the
police
to to keep him in power
the shah proceeded through the sabbath
to kill to liquidate
a large numbers of iranian citizens
sixty thousand killed perhaps although
obviously you can never get firm figures
on something like that
and a hundred or two hundred thousand
whose who physically remained or at
least their lives were ruined
and uh needless to say that that sort of
thing upsets people there's a lot of
iranians alive today who have loved ones
who are dead at the hands of the shop
and they're painfully aware the ci has
boasted endlessly about putting a shot
in power and they're painfully aware of
this association
even then we were the the coup that
ousted the shah
romani getting getting power the
religious revolt there
we were still doing okay until we rubbed
the final salt in the wound by bringing
the shah into this country
now to the iranian government and the
iranian people he is he is a monster he
committed gross crimes against
the iranian people and specific iranian
individuals
and they have called since the the coup
and he fl he fled the country they've
called for him to be returned so he
could be put on trial for crime specific
crimes murder
and all kinds of mayhem yeah john i
think they have evidence john that he
sacked somewhere between one to 17
billion dollars out of the iranian
economy in addition to killing people
yes massive theft
and
we and various other
prominent nations have instead of
cooperating to extradite him to have him
stand trial for these
bloody
and venal crimes we've given him haven
and the reaction is that the iranian
citizens the students got
overreacted of course i don't condone
they're taking over the embassy but
that's what you can expect when you
treat people that way
john i saw today in the spotlight
magazine they always seem to have an
undercover person or a spokesperson
somewhere who's willing to talk
they were saying that
their
man in the hospital where the shah is so
the shah really doesn't have cancer at
least nothing that's very threatening to
his life what he does have is a simple
case of gallstones and which could be
corrected by surgery but they're
actually keeping him there
as part of the ploy
that he's really well enough he could go
back
and
he wouldn't be very well after he went
back but i mean he could travel well he
would be tried and what would happen to
him would be up to the the iranian
system of justice
but uh
i personally i've watched the news
fairly carefully and i've it seems to be
absolutely
unacceptable intolerable
that we would send him back we would
permit him to be extradited
and yet it seems to me that we've staked
our honor on the support and protection
of a man who is somewhat of a monster
and it's going to be one of the greatest
tragedies of our modern history if our
60
government officials
die
to protect the shah i don't know how
other people feel about this but i just
can't i can't see why we couldn't have
sent him back to begin with well even
before that john isn't there a very
serious question of why carter let the
shah in the country in the first place
it was known that this would enrage the
iranian people it would be a gross
insult to them and intelligence sources
showed that there would be a possible
threat to the american
embassy there if the shah was led into
the country don't you think this was a
gross heir of carters
incomprehensible
it's an arrogance of course looking at
it other ways it's it's the kind of
arrogance that we've been guilty of for
the last 30 years particularly towards a
third world and third world sensibility
so it's not surprising to see us do this
but it was it's obviously been proven to
be a colossal blender well carter didn't
do this on his own
david rockefeller and henry kissinger
lobbied quite heavily to get the shot
into the country well we uh discussed
this last week this kissinger connection
and it's interesting that george ball
the former undersecretary of state was
on meet the press this sunday and made
precisely this point that if it wasn't
the obnoxious in his words pestering of
the state department and carter by henry
kissinger the shah would have never been
let into the country the next day
kissinger was harassed by a lot of news
people and he denied this he claims in
april of this year he did ask the state
department to let the shot in to meet
our commitments to him but he hadn't
spoken for months to the state
department they refused to comment on
this this was also confirmed once again
the spotlight they talked to
i guess under the table or had under the
table spokesperson with the house
speaker tip o'neill
who corroborated this that the
combination not only of kissinger but
david rockefeller and john j mcclure
these are the top people at the american
and the apex of american power structure
they're the ones who put such pressure
against carter too
denials in the past haven't haven't held
a whole lot of water when you consider
that john stockwell here was working in
angola at the time kissinger was it was
telling the american congress that yes
we don't have any people in angle and we
don't have any money going in there
either
an even more disturbing
story about henry kissinger
appeared yesterday in the new york times
by anthony lewis who claims that
kissinger has told the shah to hardline
it not to leave the united states unless
the carter administration publicly
invites him to do so
i think the government particularly the
rockefellers and kissinger's feel that
at all costs we must support the
dictators which we put into power and
through whose good services in the
country particularly to their police and
the secret police they maintain law and
order so that the rockefeller
multinationals and corporations and
banks can exploit the countries and
without this
implied promise of taking care of these
dictators
after they are deposed then they're less
likely to want to cooperate with the us
while they're in power that's
kissinger's position this is what he
urged on carter that if we don't take
care of our friends our friends are
going to desert us and they're going to
not have confidence in it but but it's
very important to understand that you're
talking about at that point the david
rockefeller and henry kissinger's
friends and not the friends of the
american people
it's it's the dictators who are doing
business the pinochet is doing business
with itt and it's very nice for itt but
it doesn't make any it doesn't make for
a better deal for the american people
and this is something that we must
distinguish christie you have uh some
information on just how the shaw
enriched himself do you notice one
interesting point i've just found out is
that the shah has taken 10 of the gross
profit of iranian oil since
1963 this is every year
10 and if you can imagine how much money
that is
so when they talk about 12 billion
dollars being taken out of iran by the
shah and his family
you can well believe it you know also
you think okay where is it going i mean
isn't going to a sock somewhere it's
probably undoubtedly in one of the david
rockefeller's banks it's probably in
europe also the shah has stated that he
has between one in 10 million dollars
and actually i believe that he has that
in his own personal bank account but uh
then you talk about his family and all
their bank accounts around the world
it adds up fast well john if i go back a
second to the cia and
iran
uh not only has iran itself been a play
toy of the cia for so many years but
also in that general area the cia has
ultimately supported and deserted the
kurds and their attempts to have
their own state there have they not and
this has kept the whole pot boiling yes
that's the second major crime against
humanity that the cia has perpetrated in
iran was in 1975 the shah
had a confrontation going with the the
government of iraq and as a ploy to to
bring them to terms
he asked kissinger to have the ci
intervene on behalf to support the kurds
to incite them to to rebel in iraq
and the ci went in with a major covert
action program and armed them and
encourage them to fight
then it worked and the iraqi government
came to terms and
the shah then called off the ci told
kissinger to stop supporting the kurds
as part of his conditions
of agreement with the iraqi government
and so the cia did the problem of course
was that this left the kurds dangling
the the the iraqi army was beginning to
move and it withdrew the support from
them so the ci had incited them and
encouraged them to revolt
and then uh dropped them cold and and
it's it's import another area where it's
impossible to get figures but a hundred
thousand or so were killed
and uh kissinger when he was asked about
this by the congress recalled he said
that you shouldn't confuse uh
covert action or the intelligence
business with missionary work
which strikes me as a fairly cynical
statement from a very cynical man nobel
prize winner incredible
blood blood
to his armpits at least
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people dead in this world because of
whimsical adventures that henry
kissinger has ordered
and uh
and he gets peace prize
he also gets a lot of money there was an
article recently on his income and he
receives regular incomes from the
rockefellers he got five million dollars
for his book he got a million dollars
from nbc as a commentator
so who says crime does not pay
there's another aspect of
well this would be the overt part of it
and that's the
arming of the iranian
army itself and i was reading somewhere
where until south vietnam collapsed
at that time that the iranian army
actually became the third largest in the
world in terms of hardware expense but
that's how much we had armed the shaw
this raises a very disturbing question
about iran and that is the specter of
military
solutions just today
uh president carter um it said in the
newspaper that carter made it clear that
the honor of the country comes before
the lives of the hostages and there's
been quite a few
all of them are involving some risk
and i think our military is uh likely to
be called upon to take some risk and i
think it's important that the country be
prepared
uh to do that in a situation like this
where the country is really being
blackmailed
by a foreign leader uh who seems to be
more of a religious fanatic than a
politician does that mean that there
comes a point in time when those 49
people that are in that embassy become
expendable
you want to take a cut at that yes i i
think that in the uh in the broad
context of international relations uh uh
that time is uh fast approaching and uh
i i think that you will see uh uh very
shortly uh
uh kamini takes some actions that
uh might well be uh
even more severe than he's taken already
against the hostages there's some risks
that i think all of us are expected to
take
the risk that none of us
would want to take though is to be put
out uh
on the point and then abandoned by the
nation
i think it's important that uh
anytime our people are called upon to
take risks
in the name of our nation that our
nation be willing to take those risks
too and i think that's the watershed
where we are right now and we've tried
to find a sort of a no-risk uh a way out
of this dilemma and there isn't any well
john i'd like to pose the question to
you is military intervention a viable
option what would be the consequences
of a military intervention in iran what
would happen if we either blockaded iran
or bombed their oil or tried to uh quote
liberate the hostages through military
intervention
well we would be throwing a great big
dash of kerosene into a very hot
situation in the world violence breeds
violence
and we have an enormous
islamic
population in the world today
somewhat antagonized by our recent
policies uh
if at the present time there are a
number of people outside of iran
muslims who do not support the khomeini
and what he's doing
against our embassy our installation
there but i think it's uh
certain that if we invaded iran and
killed iranians for revenge or whatever
we would turn a broad segment of those
people against us they would side with
the dead muslims and not with us
and that would have to be
let's back up a minute and note that
there is no military action possible now
while the hostages are there it would be
certain death for the hostages it would
only be punitive after and uh
which they're talking about which
they're definitely talking this is why
it's so disturbing what uh carter just
said that the honor of the country is
more important than the lies of the
hostages we have got to learn
sooner or later and the sooner the
better it's a very dangerous world we
live in we've got to learn as soon as
possible that you can't bludgeon the
world into submission
it's not possible there's too many
people out there it's too big a world we
can't go out there and hit them all over
the head and make them
do what we want them to do
we have to work with people and live
with them on this globe and if we're
going to do so peacefully
as
the most powerful nation and the richest
nation we have to establish
sincere
diplomatic efforts and leadership
towards
tolerance and peace instead of violence
and bloodshed i think there's another
situation would happen if there was
military intervention and i think we saw
the previews of that in pakistan where
the word that the
mosque in mecca had been desecrated
there was a violent revolt to the
pakistan people against the american
embassies and evidently in turkey in
bangladesh in several islam islamic
countries there have been these revolts
against the american embassies so if
there was a war with
iran if there was military action
against iran wouldn't there be an
explosion of the islamic world that
would constitute a tremendous danger to
u.s personnel and property as well as
the specter of the oil cut-offs of opec
boycotting um
oil certainly for america certainly
catastrophic for the american economy
and and back to this point in pakistan
and the way they reacted you know it's
hard for americans to understand that
kind of passionate overreaction against
us when we weren't even at fault you
know the innocent americans
what what american people have to fix in
their minds very firmly and remember in
in evaluating these situations
is that we have been guilty of bloody
aggressions in every corner of this
globe in the last 30 years through the
cia
country after country about 30 countries
that the cia has has instigated fomented
uh
actions in which local citizens were
were killed
the local people always knew
that this was being done by the ci they
knew you know their loved ones were dead
and they knew who had done it secrecy
in each of these situations was to keep
us the american people from knowing what
our government was doing
and and the result we have a situation
in the world where we feel misunderstood
i believe the great majority of the
american people feel like they're pretty
nice people
and people in iran and pakistan and
elsewhere are very quick to believe that
we would support something against mecca
because we've supported actions in so
many other places that killed so many
people
they're very passionate about having
their own relatives killed by by the
american organization
just as the americans are passionate
about their feelings of the hostages i
mean just look at
public reaction to what happened in iran
you know there are people in the streets
screaming things like nuke iran and
throwing rocks and they became very
passionate and no one had even died yet
and no one had died yeah they were just
hostile
people here really don't have any
concept of what goes on around the world
i think
that during the iranian revolution it
was something like close to a million
people died i think
between in the last 10 years and up to
the revolution it was
incredible amounts of people and i don't
think people here really understand the
full scope of that
i'm certain i'm certain we don't
and and i only hope
that americans will focus on this and
understand it and begin to reverse these
policies
to suppress and inhibit the the
kissinger type reaction towards the
world
and uh straighten our act out before
it's too late before we we have tehran
type situations in every corner of the
of the globe
isn't this working actually to the
benefit of not only committee but carter
itself and it's both to their benefit to
keep dragging it out
carter we know is that carter we know is
in trouble at home with all kinds of
political and economic problems
and humanity is in definite
well
there's some question just how much
control he actually has over the country
when gerald ford was president um
he went to war we went to war
temporarily
a country that barely was out of the
stone age and they wanted to make ford
look decisive which kind of brings up
the specter of the people in the
administration causing this particular
incident you notice that president
carter has gotten off of cuba
now that he's got iran to focus on he
was in his campaign addresses he was
always mentioning cuba in hostile terms
and now that tehran is heated up he's
off of cuba's back for the time being
but this is also resulting in the bottom
line as well bottom line many increased
defense expenditures they were saying in
the paper yesterday that this is being
upped again so from 140 to 160 billion
it makes you wonder if there's cia
involvement in the takeover of the
embassy you know
it brings out your paranoid all paranoid
all the way around
well this is why it's such an explosive
uh issue because the interests of
certain politicians romania and iran and
carter in the united states are invested
in this situation and they have more to
gain politically it seems by hardlining
it than by taking a rational
orientation to try to find a solution to
it john don't you think that the cold
war policy is really detrimental to the
interests of the people of the united
states that we at home face the dangers
of war of economic deprivation uh
because of this foreign policy so that
it's in our interest to find a peaceful
diplomatic solution to this
absolutely i've said it many many times
in my lectures and appearances that the
cia is the greatest
enemy and threat to the united states
national security
of any organization in the world it's
gotten us in more and more serious
trouble than the kgb ever has or could
or or any of our enemies
by that i mean the vietnam war was as as
as we said before on this show
was a ci operation for seven years until
their propaganda heated it into an overt
intervention and look what that cost us
in terms of the vision of the country in
terms of economic resources squandered
and 165 billion debt that we're still
coping with
and an enormous reaction on the part of
the world against us and we also have
our our aggression against cuba and
against china and against chile and
against angola against the kurds and
many many others that the cia did that
it's digging a big deep hole for the
united states and the sad thing is that
the cia
is a an unconstitutional and extra
constitutional organization it functions
illegally
our constitution is pretty clear that
this sort of thing the american people
should be able to participate in
deciding if we want to have
wars and how our tax dollars are spent
and by functioning secretly the ci is
able to get us and get us into war
without the people getting to debate and
vote
and now what's happened in a situation
like this is that the iranian situation
is perfect it brings hits the xenophobia
button it hits the racism button and our
civil liberties are
in severe danger if for no other reason
because the iranians in this country
their civil liberties are in danger and
that's where john duncan has been
fighting of probably an unpopular battle
isn't it let's um move to this issue
again john there has been we've seen a
very ugly
racist backlash against iranians in the
united states we've seen a lot of
violence against iranian people
in new jersey this one company fired all
their bus drivers that were iranian
greenville state college and i think
north carolina kicked out on maas the
iranian students a massage parlor in
austin had a sign in their window no
iranians and the government has fueled
this in a sense in the deportation
order
for iranian students whose papers aren't
in
order hasn't the aclu in the last couple
days
questioned the legality of some of this
maybe you can discuss the legal issues
our national organization has filed two
lawsuits
one has to do with the right to march
and demonstrate in washington d.c
we want everything on that one except
the question of whether or not you could
march in petition uh in front of the
white house
you get very bad law sometime
when you get a hysterical political
situation and this is a case i think a
very bad law in which we allow
the uh iranian government to take some
action that is repulsive to all of us
and then our government uses that action
as a reason to suspend the first
amendment to the u.s constitution it's
something that the public should not
tolerate
the second line our area that we've had
real difficulties with and i think where
the carter administration has really
fueled the flames of anti-iranian
resentment in this country is the order
to all iranian students and all of those
iranian visas to appear before december
the 14th
to prove that they are in the country
illegally
our national organization has filed a
suit challenging this
it was filed on november 27th
it
is a suit that says in effect that you
cannot single out iranians
and
have a special set of rules concerning
their deportation the fifth amendment
and the 14th amendment of the u.s
constitution says equal protection of
the laws for all persons past court
decisions have said that
aliens are entitled to equal protection
of the laws
and what we're saying here is that you
cannot
single out a particular nationality
and
apply the immigration laws in
an
unequal fashion john is there a parallel
to the situation of japanese people in
world war ii where they were swept up in
a dragnet and put in concentration camps
and being discriminated against purely
because of their nationality what's the
similarities and differences okay our
national office in a mayo graham a week
or so ago
addressed uh this particular issue in
terms of a step moving in that direction
a fear that if the government did not
back off and quit make fueling these
flames within the uh
this country and quit making
statements that in effect encourage
people to take actions against iranians
such as a current up in dallas yesterday
where
a
uh iranian-owned business was firebombed
and burned out
that
we would wind up with the sort of thing
that we had after world war one with the
germans in which there was a whole lot
of anti-german sentiment addressed not
against just aliens but u.s citizens of
german background or if you look at what
happened in world war ii
there the government went much further
it was not just japanese aliens that got
picked up and sent to concentration
camps in wyoming and arkansas it was
japanese-american citizens the people of
japanese ancestry who were just picked
up their businesses were taken and they
were shipped and placed in concentration
camps in wyoming and arkansas without
reference to whether where their
political sentiments lay the mere fact
of ancestry resulted in our country
doing this and yet they did not do it in
hawaii where the percentage of japanese
americans is considerably higher
john when this greenville state college
kicked out all of the students this was
declared illegal wasn't it
i think any state university that kicks
out an iranian student
has violated that student's
constitutional protections is guaranteed
under the 14th amendment i don't think
there's a bit of doubt about that and
that any official action of that variety
would be a violation of constitutional
rights there's a debate now going on
here at the university of
texas where it's a question of whether
the
college campuses should allow
this ins investigation of iranian
students on campus the university of
southern california the university of
california berkeley has said that the
government should not interrogate and
check up on iranians on campus whereas
at texas they have what is your
organization's or your own position on
this well
our national spokesman on that just made
a statement i think that it was a matter
of discretion my personal viewpoint
would be that
the university has no obligation to
provide ins with the facilities in which
to interrogate and photograph
iranian students that
if ins wants to set up their own thing
they're
they've got a legal right to do so
though we're challenging the whole
procedure
and that the universities are not
required to cooperate with them
there's another question just simply of
uh the attitudes of american people
towards iranians and it seems there's
been some quite gross racism
in uh regard to iranian people in the
united states which has sort of fueled
this intolerance um
you were on
television recently in a call-in program
and you covered some of this material
what were some of the responses of the
people calling in well there was a whole
lot of just pure anti-iranian uh
uh
questions i am you know personal attacks
in terms of if you're not far you know
if you're criticizing what we're doing
to the iranians in this country you must
be with them
a failure to understand that there are
constitutional protections and the
reason
that we
have some degree of order and some
degree of freedom in this society is
that because we have a constitution and
rules the government has to abide by but
there was a good deal of hostility
directed
at i think anyone who speaks out
for iranians this is also completely
irrational in that a good many of the
iranian students here in the united
states are not supporters of the
ayatollah khomeini or the actions that
he has been taking but they've just been
blanketed by their race as oh there's no
doubt about that
in fact if you look at what happened
when kamini came to power there were a
number of iranian students over here who
livelihood depended upon a check coming
through the iranian embassy
and as a result of tai's family ties
back to the shah and his regime there
were certain students who got their
money cut off
suddenly they were left
in this country with no visible means of
support and
in some cases having relatives shot by
the revolutionary council and such and a
prospect for going to prison if they
went back
in fact the immigration naturalization
service had been teletyping messages
repeatedly to their offices prior to
this whole episode saying
no deportation of any iranian student
until the mid-1980s at which time we
will review this it was a conscious
decision on the part of the state
department saying
there are students here who will have
real political difficulties and may wind
up as political prisoners if we send
them back to khamenei into that regime
and if you look at those who are illegal
i would suspect that the major portion
of the anti-khmeani
group of students in this country are
those who are the illegal students who
have had their money cut off and it's
totally counterproductive to hand him
those that he'd most likely to lock up
well we would offer them i'm sure the
same political asylum that we have the
shaw right well christy you know a lot
of iranians how do they feel about this
are they really confused and scared you
get a lot of different uh viewpoints
they're all scared and confused in fact
a lot of my friends right after this
whole thing hit were scared to go out to
the grocery store to buy groceries
because they knew that
people would be hanging out of cars you
know throwing rocks i know people you
know who've had their lives threatened
gotten threatening phone calls
and in a way though you really can't
blame the american people for getting
this stirred up there's a vacuum of
information in this country and what's
really going on in iran and
just
one example that really upset me was
when some of the black
hostages were coming home zeroing in on
their mothers crying as you know they
were getting the information about their
sons coming home it really whipped up a
lot of sentiment in this country whereas
you know they
didn't show at all how iranian mothers
felt when their sons were getting shot
you know
it was incredible how they manipulated
these people and whipped up this
xenophobia as someone said earlier
and you know what kind of reaction can
you expect
most iranians here understand that you
know but a lot of them have different
positions most of them do support
the embassy takeover maybe not uh
the means by which they did it it means
they use you know taking hostages but
they do support the motives
you know trying to let america know that
they mean business about getting the
shah back in iran
and that sort of sums up how a lot of my
friends feel at least what
well i think we should uh talk about
then we've been talking a little bit
here and there about the
mass media treatment of this but this is
certainly one of the big factors in
keeping the
fanning the flames and just like john we
were talking in one of our past programs
about the mass media and its handling of
the situation with cuba and the russian
troops there the
if the media of television had handled
it differently
it would have been an entirely different
locate
thing which people would have seen the
absurdity of those few russian troops
down there was training but they didn't
they kept fanning it this goes all the
way the same here this goes all the way
back earlier frank to how the american
media failed to cover the events in iran
they failed to show the torture that was
going on under the shah they failed to
show the popular resentment that was
building up in the people in iran we had
a show on alternative views about a
month before the homeani revolution in
which we were had iranian students
talking about the opposition movement
towards uh against the shah that was
reaching epic proportions it wasn't even
mentioned on network television there
was there wasn't a awareness in the part
of the american people that the
iranians were being tortured
systematically by the shah and they were
beginning to resist moreover there has
been a glorification of the shah by the
american media sort of a moderate
liberal reformer a friend of the
american people this brings us to uh the
despicable barbara walters and her
finding over the shaw
his majesty his greatness
and
last week i was extremely upset by this
interview that barbara walters got with
asha she was the only
reporter that was allowed to talk to him
in the last eight months
and she completely whitewashed this
whole
issue of the shot trying to make it
appear as if he had to come to america
for medical treatment or he would have
died she also said some interesting
things about his wealth she claimed that
the shah said that he was only worth
from 100 to 200 million um dollars oh
poor baby poor baby and uh
abc and barbara completely accepted this
as if the stories of his having taken
millions billions of dollars out of iran
were a myth well this can be documented
how much money the shah took out of iran
because also you've got to realize the
fact that he didn't all take it out on
his own person he's got plenty of
relatives who were leaving at the same
time he wasn't he just planted it on all
of them if you i don't know if anyone
knows this but his sister tried to take
something like two pounds of heroin out
of iran
to sell it abroad on the black market
and was caught in switzerland i believe
and of course they let her go you know
but this is
just an example of how they were trying
to get money out of the country
well christy you're involved now in a
movement or an organization to try to
bring people together to fight this
situation again
yeah the name of our organization is the
coalition against intervention and
racism in the middle east and it's sort
of an ad hoc type
coalition that was just formed this week
in austin and it's in response number
one
and number two to
the war moves that we're making in the
middle east the you know the kitty hawk
in the in the indian ocean and the
several uh
american ships in the persian gulf and
also the harassment of iranian students
in this country
this is sort of a collection of several
groups
just to name a few young socialist
alliance students for libertarian
society the texas libertarian party
new new american movement
these are people who have endorsed the
coalition we have some possible
endorsements rcyb
desock the texas mobilization for
survival workers world it's sort of like
a conglomerate of groups and we sort of
set up a platform
the first two which are already
mentioned and also
the extradition of the shah to iran
because uh
as we say the nobel peace prize winning
amnesty international once described the
shah as having the worst human rights
record of any ruler in the world we do
not believe in giving asylum to mass
murderers we therefore call for the
extradition of the deposed shah okay
what can you do what can you accomplish
and how how do you go about it you think
what can we accomplish well we we sort
of like to look at the roots of
situations you know people in this
country are saying well let the hostages
go well our solution is we'll send back
the shah and you solve you'd solve the
problem
because by bringing him here in the
first place we created a lot of these
problems
i mean are you getting publicity are you
writing to people or well yesterday and
today we staged two demonstrations on
the ut campus yesterday at belmont hall
where
the immigration and naturalization
service is interviewing iranian students
and today we had one on the west mall
pretty good turnout today and yesterday
we're also planning on
having a public debate on campus maybe a
forum or a public discussion on campus
and will be soon setting up a table
on the ut campus and
encouraging people to get involved in
the coalition and do what they can
and
this could this has possibilities for
going national you know this could
become a national coalition
in every city if there's military
intervention in the mideast i think
we'll have the same thing as the
anti-war movement um evolving that the
70s have been portrayed as a decade in
which people are quiet quiescent
apathetic whereas the 60s was an epic of
demonstrations but as it seems to me in
the last year we've reported on
alternative views massive demonstrations
of hundreds of thousands of people for
gay rights against anti-nuclear
energy
and
against big oil etc so that if there
seems to me there's a uh
a intervention a military intervention
uh on behalf of the u.s government in
the middle east there will be this
these demonstrations against it and it
will be i think the
uh resurgence of the anti-war movement
that is one of the purposes of this
coalition that's one of our platforms is
we are against any type of military
intervention covert or or otherwise you
know in the middle east and
we would like to try to stop these war
movies before they become more serious
than they are
yeah maybe
john if you stayed in the cia reserves
you might get called up and might get
your old job back
i don't think
he's going to give me a job back
well perhaps for the final question we
might uh raise the issue of what is the
solution to the iranian crisis several
people including christie's group have
been have called for the extradition of
the shah back to
iran
and when barbara walters asked deshaw if
he would go if the american government
sent him back he said well i've been
called many things but stupid i am not
so the shah evidently is not too eager
to
going back do you think another option
would just simply be to send him out of
the united states and to begin a
international tribunal into the
shah's crimes do you think this would be
sufficient for the iranian government
they won't or the people in the
government of iran won't be satisfied
until they get the shah back john do you
have any feelings about this well
they're not going to be satisfied with
an international tribunal that would
would clearly be protective of the shah
it's impossible in a situation
such as we have in america with the
power given the power of
president carter who brought the shy in
and henry kissinger and david
rockefeller to have
a fair trial of the shah the only place
he could get
well i'm not sure you could say you get
a fair trial in iran
if he is guilty of these crimes as he
obviously is that would be the closest
you could get to fair a trial but
certainly they would never trust
anywhere in the world western or eastern
world take care of take this
responsibility for them what about
something like the bertrand
russell wart crimes tribunal where you
have an international body of legal
experts philosophers public citizens
where you have a
so-called non-biased impartial inquiry
that sort of thing is satisfying to to
british
it wouldn't intellectuals the iranians
one day a bit
and it wouldn't satisfy the american
people at this point just like the u.n
that yeah it's uh to you know they would
conclude that he was a monster well
that's already been observed and people
have had their loved ones killed by him
and they want obviously they want blood
i personally think that the american
government is afraid of putting the shah
on trial and finding out what he will
say about what did go on in iran
absolutely i think you could probably
speak on that real well i think american
taxpayers would be quite shocked to find
out what really did go on in iran
well we'd like to thank all of our
guests tonight for providing a very
interesting discussion of the very
complex issues surrounding the crisis in
iran we haven't solved it this crisis
hasn't solved itself yet so we'll keep
looking at it and give you discussion of
these issues on alternative views good
night
and